researchers have discovered a gene that
may explain why some people with the
autoimmune disease multiple sclerosis
get sicker faster
so globally about 3 million people live
with multiple sclerosis also known as Ms
but the real number may be higher women
are more likely to develop Ms than men
when diagnosed the immune system
essentially attacks itself it attacks
the central nervous system causing
symptoms that range from numbness to
disability Ms is not an inherited
disease and doctors have struggled to
understand why some cases progress
faster than others this latest study
combed through 13 000 patients DNA it
found a gene that is linked to the onset
of severe disability
Bruce Bebo is the Executive Vice
President of research for the national
Multiple Sclerosis Society in the United
States but was not involved in this
study he said it was the first of its
kind and it could lead to better
treatments
up to now the genetic underpinnings of
the severity of disease have eluded us
and this is the first study to show a
genetic underpinning or genetic
association with the severity of Ms and
that's why this is a big deal also help
us
in combination with clinical
observations with demographic
observations and and layering on some
genetic information could perhaps help
predict what course of disease a person
is going to have early on in the course
of disease and could really help this
isn't uh you know could help Advance
Precision or personalized approach to
treatment
Sergio baranzini is a neurology
professor at the University of
California San Francisco you're the lead
author of the study and you're joining
us live from Rome today we appreciate
your time I I did my best to explain
what the study found you're going to do
a better job though so help us
understand let's go through it slowly
please what did your study find
well thank you for having me
um this is
um in fact the first study showing that
there is a genetic predisposition to
determining the course of the disease
for a long time we've known that Ms is
genetically determined and some people
are at higher risk of developing the
disease than others but eventually once
someone gets diagnosed with the disease
the disease presents in a very
heterogeneous fashion
some patients May evolve very quickly
and after five years they may be
wheelchair bound while other patients
may be still running marathons 10 years
after being diagnosed with a disease but
this study was trying to find out is
whether that heterogeneity across
patients is genetically determined and
the answer seems to be yes so why the
disease gets evolves faster in some
patients than in others
what's the benefit of identifying this
Gene now that you have found it
well for once um
know that
analysis
I helps identifying the pathogenesis of
the disease so the mechanisms behind
what's going wrong in the disease in in
these individuals and this helps
enormously to develop drugs to try to
counteract the effects so with all the
work that uh
our group together with the
international Ms genetics Consortium had
done over the past 20 years
helped identify more than 200 genetic
associations
with susceptibility to Ms and that
helped the pharmaceutical industry to
develop more than 15 approved drugs now
that treat the first phase of the
disease the inflammatory phase now this
is the first study identifying an a
genetic predisposition to faster disease
cores which will help again develop
drugs to these unmet need which is the
issue of progression okay let's address
the how like how researchers found this
can you talk to us specifically about
the genome-wide analysis and what that
is
yes in a genome-wide Association study
what we do is we collect DNA from the
blood of thousands and thousands of
patients
and with each DNA sample we interrogate
about 7 million genetic markers these
are seven million genetic changes in the
DNA sequence that may uh be linked to a
specific outcome and we look at them one
by one asking whether this could be the
one that predisposes someone for in this
case a faster or slower disease
progression what we found is that there
was one unequivocally
identified that determines that if
someone inherited inherits this
particular DNA change in a homozygote
fashion meaning both copies from Mom and
Dad
are the same this individual will
progress
much faster even at four years faster
than someone who does not have this
variance
all right Sergio baranzini neurology
professor at the University of
California San Francisco again you're
the lead author of this study I
incorrectly said earlier that you were
joining us from Rome but you're in San
Francisco thank you so much for your
time today I'm actually in Rome oh okay
well incorrectly said that you were in
San Francisco I was right the first time
it doesn't matter we so much appreciate
that you took the time to speak to us
today thank you
you're very welcome thank you